I had a coffee
what have you done but I get I get this
one isn't that a makeup like white no no
you know I don't want more bud wipes I'm
okay I think one but no eye and nose and
butt wipes okay we'll be right back
everybody your butt wipe
but white but well well Cole Cole white
oh cool what but it's a boy it's but
just so you know we were alive oh I know
this hail hey I didn't mean well no you
didn't even well ma markiplier it's all
new in the markiplier in the other
Cernan mommy priory mini da da ya I want
to be very clear that I didn't choose to
put my employer in the title this one my
mom wanted to be put in the title it's
okay I love their name mommy Claire well
that's what's important
so where were we
okay let's naughty clean this is 2nd day
right yes we did a little thing
yesterday and only one you know I always
try to spread the message of being happy
with what you have you know
you know just like nothing wrong with
striving for greatness so we're gonna be
learning some Korean today how do you
say Oh to wait to say annyeong haseyo
everybody hey where I'll be page page e
kg I think we're on a new action verbs
124 yeah okay
it Dodd basic verb is it da to district
to have the basic is ezel type of
regular verb
there's also oh oh oh ops or okay it
dies a bird like oh you have something
right to make adjectives is so hmm
take away ah you know put on their
messed up ties we don't have whatever
officer is an adjective
boom so we recycle it up wind by ball
like I told you last time
Korean love to recycle words so if you
know the verb you can interchange we
make as active or not
okay so that's to not exist to not have
so verb usage poems sigh own boat hey
I'm hang on Bob Bob Bob uses usage
sizable okay it da to exist to have you
will use this verb every day when
speaking Korean even though it da has an
S sound see it remember that when a sit
comes at the end of a character it
sounds like a tea unless it's followed
by a you in the next character this is
covered in more detail in Section five
for eat is used to say things like there
is a mmm-hmm
I have a mmm when using eateth an item
that you have or exists is marked with
the subject marker e or god thing e god
it does it says somebody's marker mean
particle same as particle like noon noon
yeah every three young people love to a
particular actor noun okay so today
you're speaking very slowly to me I
didn't get stupider between today and
yesterday I promise oh this is very
linear like do you get it you stupid
somebody out there well you didn't speak
slower for them yesterday I don't know
very well but this is gonna be on the
main channel more than 7-thousand
hopefully so like cross-sections of
demographics are the same proportion no
matter what the size usually if there's
300 people then chances are the
percentage natural population that speak
English and Korean are gonna be the same
as the cross-section it da isn't a
descriptive verb but it still uses the
rules from a prior lesson the basic form
is needed to fully use the verb fully
use the verb Yeol after the basic form
makes the sentence polite I'm not a big
phone right mm-hmm
example sentences call young eager I saw
y'all there is a cat we're young eager
young Thomas
Oh Hamas Thomas even noon
patty : Oh yummy god particle
II saw your say mock don't have a look
at ma coo coo yummy God or soil what
happened to the cab yeah Jake yeah chica
II saw y'all so there is what's your
vegetables guys particle brilliant
people use particle every now after it's
a few particle you know it's not that
many maybe five seven at the most okay
so yeah check out mm-hmm what
yes a guy you saw y'all we saw y'all
what do you say old mean I have
ordinarily this would be like in normal
conversations this like who it is being
referred to would be already discussed
well if I was like yah take East soil
the market what we went to market
yeah I mean you're asking struttin yatta
it's kind of strange adventure to voice
I take I say oh yeah
is it a vegetable here gotcha guys I saw
y'all hope you don't go to a meat market
ask me but I said of course that's it I
saw you all Korean people green meat
vendors and vegetable vendors they seem
very rude and antagonistic a mastery
I don't want to know the war is going on
in the streets yeah penny I saw y'all
pennies they are pennies till you can
say drop off this particle certain time
it's okay pain yourself you'll enjoy if
you don't know what particle go after
now get rid of it okay can you say oh
can you say y'all I need so thinning
soil thank you
yeah t sales like that where I need snow
like that good key poppy he saw you all
Kim Bobby style poppies yes we will not
use particle in there you have a noun do
you have something Kim Bobby sale what
Kim Bob it's a crazy old okay
Morgan Morgan II saw you off where what
is there no what do you have no well
then why does it say what is there more
guy look I mean more cheese though more
guys so it's a dog watching
what do you have
what are you have what do you have what
do you have been pennies
so oppa has the opposite meaning of each
eat that yeah
it also has kill Bob Jean skill bunting
double final consonant when saying the
oppa
the seal is silent and lenses followed
by a vowel when I seen the basic form of
Oh what's up salt up Saul well then both
the Butte and see it are sounded out
much like the herbs in the word obscure
oops
however I know means is the up da
obscured in the Korean language you will
certainly use it every day you speak
Korean
Co you God oops oh yo there isn't a cat
call young or you can you throw up
kind air particle and you put on you
just care well sorry Oh fine okay we are
need its can God's particle come
afternoon mm-hmm oh you can seek we
onion and up so y'all there's no such
thing as care or there's no test the
difference Chi in them yeah particle a
little more emphasized we have a door
came on East oil don't his care goodbye
qui on you know not sale rap verses
Queenie Cup say I mean somebody looking
okay okay
what is it cat we're gonna go up soon
what I'm really worried what happened to
this cat
yeah y'all say ok ok alright ok so yeah
J got hope soil hey hey slow it down see
singing yeah yeah chica yeah take that
yeah hey got good night Erica yeah hey
gods all y'all there aren't any
vegetables this is what the butcher
would say take off say out yeah butcher
Saanen common your don't yo don't sing
your dongsaeng e pop soil so what's on a
ninja i your dongsaeng e on your sister
uh-huh also y'all of course yeah gimbap
e up soil there isn't any kimbap what I
say every time I come home
through the door kimbap kimbap box oil
kimbap kimbap sir keeping Bobby Oh
kimbap kimbap all's well really I start
crying pani up so y'all you don't have a
pen you're asking by raising your any
also ok Thank You Jay my gob on me
portable room bag all soil isn't there
my back isn't Jacob on your soil take up
I'm up soil you can drop this particle
location marker yeah the location marker
a is the Korean versions of in on or act
you put it after a location to mark it
as low location where something is or
isn't we will use the new words yogi
here etc that were introduced in this
lesson example sentences yogi a Esau
y'all it's here Kogi a ops oil it isn't
there know what ok yogi in copies the
location point point here from your
point
this one is what kokyo copy or yogi yogi
it's close to you
ok oh it isn't there okay right there
are these camera what would say Kogi Bob
so you're not reached way see for coffee
your cream defined 3 Oda of e soil multi
a so we said that buddy and where is it
all the area is a particle asking in
location okay
okay some particular all these so you
can say that if you don't know remember
okay all the young so yeah my cathouses
[Music]
told toy caught young eager blue so
y'all y'all look like during the streets
of Korea looking for my cat yeah
all right good look what happened to the
cat yeah it's our war dog okay all right
chalky you saw y'all it's over there
doggy doggy so Tokyo so here therefore I
take away your is so it's like no no no
where's the cat
okay now let's make bigger sentences
that have subjects and location example
chaga yogya I saw y'all okay Carl what's
happening Chagas car yeah twice a car
tire is a particle supporting the noun
which is right mm-hm chaga okay yogi
Yemen yogi yeah just a location right
yeah so what is that yogi is here yeah
sorry oh you saw it is yours here car
here is yeah can you say China no yes I
am I am here no can you say tanum
different particle oh yeah yeah so
little slight different meaning hatha
yoga center or it cars right here okay
just entertainment China your gates
there but bicycle is out there jog a
sale see Ted Moon particle makes little
different way this point is our main
trying to make a statement is why here
right now but Theodore is right
so you put a little different particle
to emphasize it for meaning but if you
computed it
Tyagi / 5k gah
Gogi a Bob soil dogs aren't there
where's my dog
good question but it's not questions no
I'm asking I'm wondering with my dog
called yield soil oh wait no no you
wouldn't have asked no no no oh ask
somebody
where's my dog how is that where's my
goal kicker all da I saw your is they
all saw it all and I would say Oh giggle
da style and take a cookie off soil so
somebody answering dog isn't there yeah
okay guy okay cool young eager multi a
you saw y'all Oh young eager cat all da
where you saw y'all know where's the cat
so y'all cool here
Oh yummy got all da you saw y'all
where's the cat and then you just get
the guy from yesterday's Jay my chinga
friend talk EA over there he saw y'all
y'all is over there okay chinguga Tokyo
you saw y'all present oh one little tip
of advice for anyone trying to learn
Korean out there
number one have a native Korean speaker
is always very helpful we'll get a book
that doesn't do Kerr English like Kerr
English is these are just direct
translations there's no Americanization
of this helps to have someone anyway the
second book that we went to the that was
a good you know from the Japanese sure
like to invade people they were invading
Korea / than China and then they enforce
us to become a part of their culture and
learning learning language okay okay
location words are used with objects to
say things like in front of the car and
on top of the table simply add the
location word after the item followed by
the location marker hey so wet
nope mmm we we we we meet need like a
MEAP meat meat like the butcher butcher
meat kooky boy young a kooky
okay meet it's one below under down soap
sock or on inside in which ones you used
which win okay so um I'm joke okay so we
go up like this okay all right yep
next to side yeah
Oh in front of 3t dt3 yeah dee dee yes
behind example sensitive you can cover
the English of the following sentences
in guessing English based on the
pictures in the prior sentences okay
[Music]
okay
you're looking at this picture right I'm
looking at the picture you're looking at
the picture right are you gonna say okay
all right chick sun chick song mm-hmm
yeah which is on top of so check song is
desk desk we a on top of Khoya MIGA cat
II saw your desk okay now what is the
next chick song no cask meat meat meat a
meat a week a okay to eat your pronounce
okay midday with ale how you ride with
her with it you carry over a little
midday tree God let me see
say that again Twiggy God good tree yeah
90% we go to you back good as a mouse
behind the desk no no
under no oh okay wait no then I'll just
do this right so check sing so gay
little game penguin okay okay inside
penguinese penguinese penguinese he saw
y'all know y'all yeah okay alright so
check soundcheck song what is it no yup
there no pay your pay
where's your pinion next to ya bear call
me boom-boom call me call me is a bear
each particle
who me oh yeah étoile it's obvious all
okay okay no why
takes on check song check song
we got tweeting me Oh horse I think he's
a monkey beanie he's all y'all
yeah we're out he behind the desk yeah
[Music]
all the prior sentences only just gives
ok we ever follow along we the is above
on top of meat is under below meat meat
meat meat like eating meat many a88 its
prices meat sock for top inside inside
yo next
youngster up d3 bind okay
now you look at me and I'm gonna test
you okay not gonna go easy easy on me
I'm not gonna go easy on you I am NOT
gonna go is your new okay now you're
gonna say fast already my much you have
to see where is my location of my finger
good all right
yeah is that in front of it next year my
car yes my finger where is it Oh da son
s hockey ah absol Oh close go nope nope
nope
soap blue nope get up what do you say
this one is out right uh-huh
it's a heal sound come first up and what
is it no no wait no
[Music]
yeah food me me me okay not here do you
good job what is it yo oh oh we didn't
go this one oh wait no also kind of okay
okay Shh you almost blocked crema so
stressful
all right it's like if I had failed it
you would have you would have been
honorbound to just kill me right on the
spot I think this is what the states
there were stupid or biting here all
right
all the person is is how to pattern oh
there is an animal on top of the desk
with the topic of the sentence being the
location however if we want to make the
animal the primary topic we would change
the sentences to the ones below
kiyoung 'man cat check song check song
desk
we a on up on top of or above a soil so
the cat is on top of the desk
yeah so instead of being just there is a
cat you're talking about the cat he's on
top of the death yeah
you emphasize by putting the Queen in
front right uh-huh
really glad we found out where this cat
was cuz I was getting worried
so tree Queenan cleanin which is mouse
check song desk midday which is under
meat a meat meat there under I saw you
okay here is the computed
before for example who I mean on as a
subject I took a math cat by check sang
is the noun as a desk and we is a part
of a location particle what is this on
top I saw a bird right yeah let's look
at the example before prior checks are
we it's a location now check somewhere
okay location you can switch it that's
what I mean and put a subject after
location okay we are you guys so y'all
ya see that
oh you check some we're on top of a desk
queer NiCad easy okay for query month
check somewhere sir
the cat is on top of dude yes got it
yes he can go switch I'm sure you know
I'm gonna say my oh yeah no yeah because
it's like it's object direct object like
it's subject object yeah this spoon is
here or like there's a spoon here you
know it's general just think it's a
queen we use in the end ok good for that
penguin penguin checks on desk okay oh
we didn't do that inside so that's also
not solid gay what is it so can we talk
inside
yeah okay okay I did not test you use
for that
okay side lucked out I wouldn't go yeah
okay okay I saw you in the desk okay
come come on bear check song desk
yup y'all pay next to your bear I saw
y'all tonight
really can you amazing Oh beer I can't
imagine a giraffe body it's got the bird
side the blade not really stretching the
limits of my imagination
ha ha ha mana check song
so y'all well she's like whispering dear
classmate yo you went to school tripping
on shrooms or something here's like it's
no that's right snow is water and I this
is I so then heating the key demon chick
song draft desk ta
behind he saw y'all behind okay what
just happened what is the difference
between the first and second side the
censuses II and goth subject Markel
markers have changed to them and men
topic markers furthermore the order of
the sentences are different since a
topic should start the sentence the
English also completely changes further
down the rabbit hole so why isn't mmm
topic marker used after the location in
the first set of sentences you can
actually say annan the nun isn't needed
unless you wish to see this ones that
keep saying topical marker I mean I'm
pretty good book we would cover they say
particle yeah
particle seems a little easier yeah well
particle is a more direct translation
I think this one's a little off yeah you
can say in inin the nin isn't needed
so check song desk VA on top of noon
Rhiannon Gurion eager cat I saw y'all
okay you put this particle on the weird
location okay an 8 particle right
you put noon by emphasizing those
senators ok check some women wearing I
sell and take some botanic a guys so
yeah you just make a emphasize and why
or their location by or you can say
chicks and we're quitting Isao Tomita
care guys ok stalker but when you say to
sentence I emphasize it strongly edge of
the world
you put noon particle that's what I
meant this is where this is it there ok
oh so you had two things in a sentence
it yeah this is right here and that's
right here ok cuz it's like it's just
like an English like a link you just say
like this is right frickin okay alright
suck them on both mean inside in let's
look at women to use each one hmm on is
used when you can open and look inside
oh oh this is what I was asking you to
think that's what okay on is used when
you can open and look inside bags and
refrigerators can be opened buildings
and other structures have doors Oh be
hang guy uh P gang is what P hang
airplane keys particle B hang comp genki
genki
hankies honor easy oil so yeah
you saw oh Jenny is there are you inside
an airplane
chingu Noon Jhin German huk huk Your
Honor II saw your are you not in this
you know my friend chinguga jingling ha
you saw your friends in the school yeah
cheep-cheep
she's house yeah house she honor II saw
your it's inside the house okay all
Malinin
mother yo one don't know young one don't
one come it's a pony it's a sickness one
is a place of hospital on there an
inside oh boy oh my mother is in the
hospital
yeah I'm surprised that managed to stay
out of the hospital for long I have I
was like clockwork clockwork like every
year and a half or so in the hospital
for some reason or another soap is used
in abstract places that you cannot open
or see inside liquids and non physical
locations such as dreams in your head or
your heart use soap
so modey modey so gay II saw your Oh
what is that mean what smarty mean head
so gay okay sir
so what what do you have in your hand
nothing hopefully something good we
never know yeah
jae-hwan mall we went there yesterday
yeah I'm on one sounds like a nightmare
okay it's walking ha ha
[Laughter]
hippos are terrifying oh no no no hippos
are like 12 tons of death so many people
died to hippos I thought it was kind of
a comical every time I think of all oh
yeah you'll die hilariously my mother
every time you say look at the Disney
character you know that's all from
Fantasia
is the baby hippo in the Cincinnati Zoo
now that hippo is cute
but it's gonna grow up to be a death
machine okay J my or I know okay this is
you know oh my is my okay my Mon oh yeah
okay it's all gay inside Tom Cheney
eenie meenie
oh you is in the darling you version
yeah okay
II saw you oh my God if you love to
listen Korean music especially oh yeah
like your favorite kpop band BTS uh III
don't know what stuff new one are you -
classical like what
who's classic oh it's old - mm-hmm
Toyota pure joy anybody not to ampere I
don't but to appeal that was very very
most 1985 around
he's old Oh anyway every Korean pop song
you hear machine darling you are my
heart to 90999 percent they will say how
did she need my heart yeah so when I
want to go and become a kpop star I
gotta I gotta learn this song there this
sentence J mom okay you I'd my fade wig
J Morrie's okay Seanie
you're in my head out of my head you
know I never I don't think they ever
said models to be nice okay so so again
in goodness or gainin so good but school
goon the dream mmm so again an chinguga
friend inside friend man I or my nail in
my tire what is it in my dreams there
are many friends my mom
Oh
[Laughter]
now me up are y'all talkin on or
sometimes interchangeable with small
physical locations
Dabangg bag on a Oh
inside gimbap be yo yo is that just like
there's loose sushi in my bag gimbap so
k so gay kimbap II know I'm there
okay this is the sometimes
interchangeable either spoke I mean okay
so that's it was good how about animals
I'm Kim Bobby Bobby kimbap mm-hmm that's
two to gob on okay kimbap II you saw
y'all does that make more sassy you know
kabamaru
Gandhari because you can open it right
right I want a steak house okay you can
save that by its kind of undead tic song
desk on inside Benny and ops ops oil
there isn't a pen in my desk
yeah check some desk
it's okay any impulse oil okay I will
use cool our name but I'll open the
desperate yeah because Texans who can
open it and you know it's for gets more
like yeah like intangible joystick to a
new boo and new God both mean who knew
goo is used when who is the object such
as who do you love Lou gaw is used when
who is thus and subjects such as who is
coming if you ever want to say new googa
just shorten it to new
new guca Jordans - new new guy you saw
y'all who is there
you guys I hope man with you from from
Newton new goo - new goo gah and then
you guys know God is style same thing
yeah he saw you always the same thing is
you should work putting on people love
to keep a lot of work or the point okay
mmm so that's what we're seeking most of
all subjects sentence even bother to ask
you and I'm asking you stirred that no
sentence gotcha
okay bum room on a ins in inside Luger
he's so yo nice that room yeah come on
come on a pond are there you guys stay
on you guys étoile do cool grandson guy
you saw y'all would see leads much you
do guys yeah question and answer your
don't your them sang your dongsaeng
younger sister II saw y'all nah oh you
saw your sister nay he saw you oh yes I
have audio no I don't have an audio up
soil soil no no no no no audio no Bob
soil I don't have cholan I Nam don't say
me younger brother Esau Oh cousin my
cousin my what is the older brother
again mommy's not very Korean puppy um
fix okay okay go ahead
alright
Nando's and
yeah you see this bubble-bubbles a
troublemaker I've always loved with the
Bell bubbles is a little douche we'll
see what it is no no no uh where were we
all right G hey yeah
songs hang Nieman oh ha shop ta teacher
that's a name ga-ga-ga song singing
teacher hey what's going on it's my song
saying 'man all the egg where I saw
y'all where is where's
you asking question weird you saw it all
okay where is teacher you said gee a
chalky a he saw y'all
she's over there or something I worry
very much about the structural integrity
of this table he seems to move quite a
bit you know oh yeah yeah I know it's
like we're definitely still on top of
you Oh how do you live with that I don't
put him outside or something okay okay
chalky a over there mm-hmm
he's all she's over now young woman--a
oh that took a turn
she's at the hospital you soil well you
know let's say teenager female name
she's in hospital hope so just be
visiting someone
maybe she works a side job dong dong is
restaurant yeah okay cool
Juden Juden tangerine all the a where I
saw your yo-yo you saw your he said oh
you saw your Oh cute it's a tangerine
you can say without own which is
particle so cure audio so cute ah da say
oh when you put particle illness or
emphasizing you find apple so you want
to know where q this way yes so you have
cute on audio say
that was a little bit no you have Apple
you know you find out why you want to
have a tangerine mine so cute or not
they say oh where is that parking lot
Oh cute and in make a little emphasize
um you have at this opposite by you want
to get the other one okay right Gabon on
a cob on beg honey he saw your but have
fruits and foods in the bed God on a you
saw y'all it's in the bag check some
desk 383 a ta ta a little high yeah you
saw y'all behind the desk purely purely
purely tangerine ops oil I don't have a
dangerous or you can say just cool off
so yeah
good or not the ASA children audio I
don't intend dreams I didn't buy enough
tangerine stocks keep that polite
conversation between co-workers new
nagas soil new now guys older sister no
no no you saw y'all do you have an older
sister yeah
yes I saw y'all all the air all the
aerial okay where is your where she
where is she
oh yeah I'll be aware you say up what
this is like this doesn't seem like a
polite conversation between coworkers it
seems like this co-worker wants to date
this person sister well these do you
have a little sister where is your older
sister exactly tell me is specifically
noisy
serious butonce today come sir friends
Oh France Bhutan Bhutan see a yo-yo
she's in France as far away from you as
possible yeah like a conversation
between friends on the phone bolli oh
you got it I'm sorry oh the a oh where
are you oh you can see you Oh pl
where is it where are we oh they are
y'all good Yale ODL Turin
I jib jib a gym that's not inside yeah
she no no she bears I thought sulking on
where inside she bought in you can see
Barney we're in a minute okay
you want to put cheap on there that's
fine no Nazi bun yeah keep only cheapest
house oh oh
Toland cheap eh he's so yeah I am in my
house
yeah Omar Omar Omar mother mama
Oda where I saw y'all we're all mornin
Oda Esau a man an Oda sir y'all all
Noddin the OVA so y'all young woman a
young woman is hospital II saw your oh
she's in the hospital casual
conversation between friends at school
suit all suit homework mana
okay
stay home on cars particle what's mana
mana much like a lot nah okay so between
the
friend okay so you don't you take away
yo okay
what's your friend you're gonna put you
in there you'll become too much please -
I will just say to Fred please could you
please you don't do that right so you
take away you buy if you were talking to
little older people like mana yes lots
sook homework all your war audio
what auto walk hard is it hard work hard
hard
ani that's a short version of it I know
I know it's not a big I need to sunny
it's normal casual see sees real swans
short she one she wore yeah sure
it's not that easy when she wore it so
easy but pronouncation it's not easy way
audio well right okay let conversation
on the phone new gonna say your new
gizelle is a all which is who is it
Jordan saw now we sold Ally finale so
now II
tingu friend mm-hmm
Georgie Georgie yo yo George George yeah
this is saunas friend George yeah ma I
am mm-hmm when asked friend sworn
Arden's
alright
cheap bear cheaper house he saw your
question you saw your phone an antibody
or no swollen name home honey
Koenig a airport is soil all re case
I'll get I get I guess I guess Amita I
guess Sunita I mean very obviously you
asking your friend of would ops wanna
ride yeah yeah your George was for
another son all right
asking voice one hour so obviously I'm
neither father or older brother or
whatever right mom so you say oh okay
thank you
right so you just say I guess Amida I
understood it soon as I understood okay
I doesn't mean that I guess me yeah I'd
ask my dad I guess meet up then you say
come sangha thank you I'll guess I guess
a new da come suddenly that can tell me
that okay
conversation between friends do you have
a car charger I saw your give Korra a
neon no chaga of soil I don't have a car
O'Bannon Obama burnin up burnin chaga
O'Bannon is older brother would you say
to you your your brother say oppa you am
boy
your brother right would you call these
Thomas as oppa which a boy call is your
older brother an OPA this is someone
else no no me younger female call older
brother as oh okay you're a girl if you
a girl okay I'm a girl right
I have older brother right if I have
older brother I'll call Appa I'm sorry
I'm just distracted by the extreme
humping that's happening don't worry
I'll have a no clueless
he's up to give us that India but see
your hopper hopper
Oh your hop up what you're hoping my
back never succeeds he tried I never
succeed yet yet yes being the qualifying
word yeah you know controlling the dog
population is very important getting
your dogs fixed is very important to
many dogs in shelters
I know bells I want to have one I guess
okay all right Bob I'm totally
forgetting you're female you call older
male oppa
O'Bannon so Targa is soil you know you
know you know the Kangnam style in a
song what is color if you listen to that
you'll hear oppa oppa Gangnam style oppa
Gangnam style you see that
oppa mean the female yeah female calling
actually in Korea it doesn't matter
you're older younger a girl call you
oppa oppa even you're strange of the
Copa
Oh bah you hear a lot of work but why
because it's kind of friendly okay all
right
Obama and cha-cha-cha soil taka I saw
y'all did your brother have a car
Nick ja e soil yes a car yo yo it is
common in Korean to drop particles when
speaking gah is dropped here yeah polite
conversation between friends who is at
school ha you're a hockey Oh a school
new guy which is new googa new you gonna
shorten Esau y'all I use it
he saw y'all at school so new Gallo eat
soy yo he's also a good sentence as long
as you keep the particles with the
proper word you can move them without
affecting the meaning Jay I owe Baga
older brother my older brother Esau
y'all your dongsaeng got your own sand
or your thong same door boys also
Oh doll it's time later in the book it
also means also your long single hot gay
I saw y'all so my sister younger sister
is also experienced so particle in Korea
it doesn't come before now it's always
come after more the particle to support
the meaning of the world ya ta so yeah
Annie oh no oh so y'all know they're not
so you're them saying that oh no y'all
don't say how dull don't y'all don't
sing doll huh Q so y'all that was a
question saying your younger sisters
also know she's not cheap a house he's
so you know she's at home yeah yeah
flight conversation is that meat spicy
good good that go gainin loading then
mean may wall y'all may boil man why
y'all spicy Ned
yes Mae Abajo very spicy - spicy
Oran om G or ng orange
juice Agha juice étoile
ong just do do sudah e soil guys weren't
it just guys so y'all what orange juice
Lisa this is Lauren teacher soo god of
soil I don't have orange juice also
booty oil water soil Moody's or yeah
wait the ones yeah
in each lesson we will build on a
previous sentence watch the grown
transform so Jay my all mom even mother
GABA me bag all soil doesn't have a bag
ok Cobham it to me it's a little bigger
than hands hands first
okay well how was it called hand purse
house say hi man occurs in Korea Korean
[Music]
Lucy don't you barking at yeah so
reading comprehension oh yeah oh those
are the old ones no vocals eagleson
Royale what is this yeah ii p Jonin ma
she saw y'all
yes pizzas delicious Jay Oh mommy aah
mommy aah mommy we my mother's Pete Alan
hog olive oil cold my buddies is cold
ok now your current level you should
understand all the grammar and words in
the following sections if you're
struggling to understand the review this
very list so
banana banana yo Bey ok ok ok
hi
yeah no yup a young face no next - wait
what's front what are we talking about
that's front pay up your bed next
to banana next to check e-book you say
oh the bananas next to the book the book
is the book is next to the banana right
okay good good check good means ooh okay
wait good wait chicken book this book
means ooh the name means who means you
see we mister means ooh is mr. means
whose check EA oh yeah I'm taking you
this book is mr. immune Seuss book okay
means to see mr. means who's top Gina
not charging you don't know Tommy's
penis right chop Jimin all the a East
oil means to mr. mean sues chop junín
magazine magazine all da e soil where's
mr. ensues don't ever say you know what
where's mr. means is being it means is
Huey chum Gina there is aa
water means is me
[Laughter]
all right gob on bag on a inside soil
it's it's not the best peeta peeta peeta
be a DJ we lose out what yeah yeah we're
Jackie so we JA occasion no no no it's a
what is it yeah cheer we job yeah
location on top of check e-book yo-yo is
there a book on the chair
yeah I say y'all he saw y'all honey off
no oops oh you know there's Sagwa apples
I want so I got your bear what is your
pick next to ya
you saw y'all there's an apple next to
ok wait is that an answer how about your
face well the question is is there
magazine where's the magazine ways not
but the answer is Apple's next to
because you stole Tim it's mad at you
wha yeah that answer does it make sense
so chop G then banana
is the banana I'm sorry I've forgotten
my family friendly actually just a
little in a we be their checkbook new
GUI where whose check Yale whose book is
this book what are they sit book twice
do Kakashi area actually you're right
this is the English Way of saying
actually
if you want to repeat the same thing
yeah you can use God do go gosh you do
cook gosh yeah it's a good negotiator
it's more natural actually good point
okay
nothing you tickle new CEO it's very um
not likely
okay time to stop anyway cuz well thank
you guys so much for this